[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité de cette
édition tout d'abord le cri de colère
des petits commerces face à la pression
qui commence à monter l'état pourrait
faire un geste dans les prochains jours
nous regardons ensemble lequel dans
l'actualité également c'est une
tradition française le beaujolais
nouveau arrive mais voilà en plein
confinement la filière est durement
touchée nous examinerons ces
problèmes-là de près dans un instant
enfin cap sur le bassin d'arcachon
depuis le début de l'année les
ostréiculteurs du bassin ne sont pas
épargnés certains ont du mal à voir le
bout du tunnel
les explications de nos confrères de
tele7 en fin de journal nous commençons
ce journal par un cri du coeur laissez
nous travailler où nous allons tous
mourir
donc on n'en sont donc par la situation
des petits commerces de proximité que
l'on a pu entendre cette semaine à saint
chamond dans la loire lors d'un
rassemblement des petits commerçants
la perspective de pouvoir ré ouvrir dans
les prochains jours et dans toutes les
têtes
comme nous le montre ce reportage de nos
confrères sur place de tl7 télé loire 7
7 6 y mon un magasin de cosmétiques
je suis photographe rendez nous notre
droit de travailler où nous allons tous
mourir la détresse ir matin des
commerçants de saint chamond qui ont
organisé un pique nique géant place de
la liberté
sur le parvis de l'église notre-dame ils
ont symboliquement simuler la mort du
commerce de proximité
la nouvelle fermeture administrative est
vécue comme une injustice
en effet les lieux où l'affluence est
bien plus massive que dans nos magasins
peuvent rester ouverts alors qu'ils ont
tous des sites et des plateformes
internet qui fonctionne parfaitement
ça m'a coûté 16 mille euros de
trésorerie sur le premier confinement
heureusement que j'étais là depuis 28
ans que j'avais une trésorerie un peu
d'avancé qui m'a permis de passer ce cap
mais si un deuxième confinement dure
encore trop longtemps je vais je vois
pas comment on va pouvoir passer le cap
financièrement gestes-barrières aération
des boutiques filtration des clients ou
distribution de gel les commerçants
savent appliquer faire respecter le
protocole sanitaire
courir est une nécessité économique
psychologique aussi
l'état économique est catastrophique et
le moral on fait aller parce qu'on
essaye de d'être tous ensemble mais bon
on fait bonne figure
évidemment qu'on y croit toujours tout
ce qu'on veut c'est pouvoir continuer à
travailler ou de terre contre pot de fer
grande distribution et commerce en ligne
contre magasins de proximité
ceux qui sont désormais considérés comme
non essentiels estime au contraire être
essentielle pour le lien social et la
vie des quartiers
voilà quelques semaines des fêtes de
noël les catholiques du monde entier se
mobilisent en france des manifestations
ont eu lieu un peu partout pour demander
le retour des messes dans les églises
nous nous rendons maintenant dans les
yvelines où nos confrères de tv 78
étaient présents lors de ce défilé
regardez le reportage
plus de 1000 personnes à versailles 300
à saint germain en laye à rambouillet
les catholiques chinois étaient
mobilisés ce dimanche devant les lieux
de culte des rassemblements de déclarer
en préfecture comme ici devant sainte
bernadette à rambouillet et demandent le
retour de la miss
très concrètement ce qu'on demande c'est
que il ya vraiment ce principe de
laïcité qui soit reconnue avec une
véritable séparation entre l'église et
l'état et de laisser l'église organisé
en fait les règles sanitaires à
l'intérieur de ses propres célébrations
pour le moment les églises sont ouvertes
et les fidèles peuvent s'y recueillir
individuellement mais pour les
catholiques cela ne suffit pas la messe
doit être célébrée ya deux dimensions
dans la presse la première c'est la
dimension du rassemblement voilà le
catholicisme est une religion qu'on ne
pratique pas seuls et pas chez soi ou
donc à pas seulement vous plaît et puis
la deuxième dimension c'est que la messe
est une action il se passe quelque chose
c'est ce qu'on appelle liturgie voilà
donc la de cet acte religieux
n'a plus lieu et ça c'est embêtant mois
là mais c'est donc pour les chrétiens
essentiel c'est un moment qui permet aux
fidèles de s'unir autour de la foi quand
on est catholique
on croit en jésus et dans la messe ni à
jésus pour nous voilà pourquoi c'est
important
c'est comme si on parlait de quelqu'un
et qu'on ne voyait jamais ne pas avoir
de metz
c'est lundi 16 novembre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a reçu les
représentants des cultes pour échanger
sur les évolutions possibles des
pratiques de la religion compatible avec
les règles sanitaires
je vous le disais dans les titres un
goût de fraise de bananes ou de cassis
vous ne pouvez pas vous tromper
il s'agit bien du beaujolais nouveau qui
est arrivé cette semaine une tradition
française bien sûr mais en pleine
période de confinement la filière
viticole et durement touchés dont
confrères de la loire sont allés dans
une coopérative agricole dans les
vallons des pierres dorées en plein
coeur du beaujolais la nature arbore ses
couleurs d'automne pieds de vignes à
perte de vue
le vignoble s'étend sur sept mille
hectares gamay et chardonnay sont les
principaux cépages à taizé une bande de
copains de joyeux lurons déguste la
cuvée 2020 du beaujolais nouveau
à la veille de la mise sur le marché du
millésime les saveurs explosent en
bouche 250 vignerons sur mille hectares
forme e doria chaque année cette cave
produit 18 mille hectolitres de
beaujolais nouveau rouge et rosé c'est
ta tiers du volume total de la
coopérative en fin de chaîne de
conditionnement les bouteilles comme à
leur habitude danse maîtrise sanitaire
oblige le coeur n'y est pas le
beaujolais nouveau stade en fait un vin
de convivialité à 22
deux copains ont fait ça entre amis on
fait ça dans des cafés hôtels
restaurants ont fait ça sur des fêtes
dédiées au beaujolais nouveau et cette
année tout est supprimé il y aura ce
petit goût de manque
manquant convivialité perte de chiffre
d'affaires même si l'essentiel de la
production est vendue en gros à des
négociants 15% du marché est destiné
habituellement à des commerces
aujourd'hui fermée sur les cafés hôtels
restaurants on perd 90 % du chiffre
d'affaires on ne sait pas quand clé
quand les restaurants vont réouvrir
quand les barbes on pourra accueillir
encore de la clientèle et ça personne
n'est capable de répondre
et moi je m'inquiète aussi par rapport à
nos amis à metz d'orateur des clients en
moins mais surtout les premiers
ambassadeurs des produits
christian du teil tient le 7 vers
d'ordinaire le troisième jeudi de
novembre est synonyme de fête et de
forte affluence
cette année le restaurateur est
nostalgique le jeu 10 ans d une
dégustation de beaujolais avec tous les
vignerons de la région et après on fait
d'aller me mentionnait le vendredi soir
le samedi soir et le dimanche c'est
année c'est tout fermé jusqu'au
printemps prochain les stocks devraient
s'écouler plus lentement l'impact
économique de la crise pour les
producteurs du beaujolais pour l'instant
modérée mais un décalage de trésorerie
est à prévoir coutumier du bon sens
paysan les vignerons avaient anticipé et
réduit leur production de beaujolais
nouveau au profit du vin de garde
nous restons bretagne pour évoquer la
colère des ostréiculteurs de la ria
d'etel un petit fleuve côtier du
morbihan une manifestation a eu lieu à
la suite d'une diffusion d'une publicité
du groupe bric cette semaine mettant en
cause l'aspect sanitaire des huîtres sur
place l'opérateur a très vite présenté
ses excuses et rattraper le coup et sept
semaines des dirigeants de wig sont
venus à la rencontre de ces
ostréiculteur à lorient avec pour
objectif de montrer leur soutien à la
profession à reportage de karine
chevrollier pour la chaîne tébéo sur
place la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
colère oublier bonne humeur au rendez
vous et même un clin d'oeil aux
ostréiculteurs
après la réaction suscitée autour de
leurs publicités
les dirigeants de l'opérateur de
téléphonie mobile tenait à afficher leur
soutien à la profession en moins de 48
heures le spot mis en cause a été retiré
et remanié on a tout de suite compris le
malaise de la profession et donc on
s'est dit avec une pub dont le but est
de faire rire les gens peut pas rester
là dessus donc on s'est organisé pour
tout changer très vite
on avait envie de célébrer ça tous
ensemble aujourd'hui donc c'est la même
équipe qui nous a offert un soin de
vitrines mercredi qui revient
aujourd'hui pour présenter ces produits
n'a été quand même très surpris que ce
soit qui réagissent aussi vite
on est content quand même de notre
action parce que ça affecte même effet
le parvis de la boutique lorientaise
s'est donc transformé ce samedi un stand
de promotion de l'huitre un signal
positif pour ce secteur déjà touchés par
le norovirus en janvier dernier est
toujours en souffrance avec la crise
sanitaire actuelle al'approche défaite
les ostréiculteurs planche sur d'autres
moyens de distribution faut la repenser
notre commerce habituel parce que toute
cette partie de restauration pour
l'instant est fermé donc il faudra voir
si on peut envoyer directement des huit
chez les gens avoir un service direct et
utiliser tous les méthodes pour
commercialiser au mieux et aller vers le
consommateur au plus près l'intégralité
des recettes générées 70 par la vente de
bourriche sera reversée aux hôpitaux de
france dans le cadre de la lutte contre
la copie de 10,9 la sphère entre les
ostréiculteurs et bouygues est donc bien
digéré toujours les ostréiculteurs cap
sur la gironde et le bassin d'arcachon
je vous le disais les titres où ils ne
sont pas épargnés une nouvelle fois
après le confinement
les stocks ne se vendent pas autant dire
que certains ont du mal à voir le jour
et le bout du tunnel
les explications avec nos confrères de
tv 7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest sur
place en gironde
al'approche des fêtes de fin d'année le
moral est loin d'être au beau fixe chez
les ostréiculteurs du bassin d'arcachon
pourtant en plein préparatifs les vents
contraires se succèdent après le premier
confinement une perte d'activité de deux
mois c'est la mortalité qui touche plus
de 50% des huîtres en moyenne alors que
le deuxième confinement réduite encore
leurs ventes
l'incertitude parce qu'on ne sait pas
trop comment ça se passe et nous ré
on espère que ça va bien se passer c'est
c'est quand même 30 % au niveau romand
karenni des bac rempli de coquilles
vides provenant des parcs un travail
quotidien au fil des marées réduite à
néant mortalité a touché à la fois le
déchet à la fois le 18 mois et un enfant
est à la fois l'art râble donc comment
pour le constater d'aller dans les
coquilles ici c'est une perte générale
sur trois années
donc le tome deux rôles assez les stocks
si le décès cette année qui est en
rapport à un peu de retard sur les
échéances en trois ans par contre si
encore la mortalité dans le décès de
cette année sera pas en grosse
difficulté quoi on sera obligés ou
d'acheter à l'extérieur faire quelque
chose si on veut continuer à vivre avec
l'espoir de pouvoir vendre leurs
productions les bassins d'affinage se
remplissent peu à peu au fil du tri fait
à terre avant les prochaines marées et
le retour au travail sur les parcs pour
les 280 entreprises ostréicoles
d'aquitaine qui produisent chaque année
7000 tonnes d'huîtres
et puis puisque nous sommes en gironde
parlons de bordeaux regardez cette
édition locale cette semaine du point
consacré à la métropole d'aquitaine
bordeaux enquêtent sur l'insécurité
c'est la une du point cette semaine avec
l exaspération des bordelais
l'insécurité qui met la ville sous
tension réseau pourquoi les mineurs
isolés inquiète les bordelais et puis
également l'immobilier jusqu'ici tout
allait bien à bordeaux qu'en est il la
côte quartier par quartier quoi de neuf
les équipes de valérie ppr et de jérôme
cordelier rédacteur en chef politique du
poing se sont intéressés à la cote de
l'immobilier à bordeaux enfin bien sûr
plus agréable les caves de vin comment
les composés confinement votre décrit
notre confrère du point enfin une place
vendôme à la bordelaise celle de la
place de la bourse et de la fontaine des
trois grâces une place vendôme donc à la
bordelaise dans le point édition
spéciale bordeaux que je vous signale
nous prenons le chemin de la sarthe à
présent et nous partons du côté du
théâtre de la bertauge un véritable îlot
de cultures et de convivialité
au coeur du quartier des sablons il
permet aux gens de venir vider leur sac
et de faire face à la morosité ambiante
les lutins du père noël ont pris
d'ailleurs possession des lieux et ils
ont ouvert une boîte vocale véritable
bureau des plaintes
une blague oui mais aussi un projet
culturel qui donne à sourire anthony
python pour re via entebbe sartre sur
place oui oui vous n'aviez pas fini de
vous plaindre
eh bien écoutez continuer d'accord la
voir voilà bon écoutez derrière le
téléphone l'un des trois lutins du
théâtre de la bertoche ces trucs qui
prend les appels du bureau des plantes
et autres jérémiades anonyme entre le
confinement la fermeture des commerces
et le boulot qu'ils continuent pour lui
tout le monde a une bonne raison de se
plaindre
dans les conditions actuelles trop de
morosité président et ses voiles à venir
se plaindre à un endroit qui est prévu
pour ça plutôt que de se plaindre un
petit peu toute la journée tout le temps
on le fait un bon coup on essaie de se
concentrer vraiment sur ce qu'on a envie
d' et là après on sent leur faut pas
hésiter à respirer après on laisse le
temps
et vous allez voir le bien fou que ça
fait le bureau des plaintes est ouvert
tous les jours jusqu'au 1er décembre de
18h à 20h puis le théâtre proposera un
calendrier de l'avent en podcast chaque
soir sur le site de la bertone on y
retrouvera une sélection des plaintes
des intervenants il faut se réinventer
alors c'est vrai que ça demande une
énergie folle mais mais il faut se
réinventer nous on est très malheureux
de pas pouvoir accueillir les gens dans
notre théâtre
on est ici un théâtre où la convivialité
est toujours de mise on a on avait
l'habitude de faire des repas avec avec
nos spectateurs de faire des choses
comme ça tout ça ça a disparu
nettement au mois de mars et et la 11e'
comment on va à la rencontre de nos de
nous habituer ou de ou des futurs des
futurs spectateurs parce que nous on y
croit bien que bientôt le théâtre de la
vertonne va rouvrir ses portes
en attendant le bureau des plantes et
autres jérémiades anonyme est ouvert sur
répondeur au 02 72 91 35 29
les acteurs n'exclut pas de faire des
messages laissés la matière première
d'un futur spectacle
voilà c'est la rubrique écorégions de ce
journal direction la normandie bonjour
michel picaud vous allez nous parler
d'une société d'une pme qui s'appelle
wim et qui a su faire évoluer après le
premier confinement son activité bonjour
vous et je voulais vous parler
aujourd'hui de la pme normande de wim
installé tout près de rouen elle
fabrique des cabines pour travailler
s'isoler dans un open space par exemple
ou encore dans un stand sur un salon
professionnel seulement voilà la crise
sanitaire est passée par là il a fallu
revoir la copie on ne travaille plus
comme avant wima du donc se réinventer
en installant dans ses cabines un
système de filtration de l'air antico
vide et l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
puisque la pme a levé 2,5 millions
d'euros et va proposer ces cabines aux
collectivités aux gars aux aéroports
centres commerciaux et ils vont plus
loin en faisant des télécabines de
télémédecine cette fois ci totalement
équipées bien sûr et qui pourrait bien
contribuer à lutter contre les déserts
médicaux
encore trop nombreux dans nos
territoires vous le voyez on ne manque
pas d'idées et de technologie maintenant
dans le monde nouveau il faut y aller
voilà merci michel picaud on vous
retrouve dans une prochaine édition du
grand jt des territoires
nous nous rendons en moselle maintenant
ou deux grands noms de la restauration
ont décidé de s'associer et de racheter
un restaurant l'alexandre premier qu'ils
ont rebaptisé le clos des chefs un
restaurant évidemment prête à ouvrir ses
portes quand on pourra aller dîner ou
déjeuner au restaurant
en attendant des jours meilleurs ces
chefs se lance dans une livraison et
dans la vente à emporter
un reportage de nos confrères sur place
de moselle tv regarder tous nos légumes
sont des légumes frais comme vous pouvez
le constater des légumes frais qui
accompagneront le bourguignon ou encore
le cabillaud sauce vanille des plats du
jour
raffiné mijotés par deux chefs
passionnés et qui seront mis sous
barquettes livraison et vente à emporter
ce n'était pas vraiment la vocation du
clos des chefs ce nouveau restaurant de
marly a ouvert au début du rpt
confinement alors il a fallu adapter son
savoir faire sont des recettes qui
doivent être descendu en température et
remise en température par les clients il
faut qu'on s'adapte c'est à dire que les
sauces sont un petit peu moins lié les
garnitures sont un petit peu différente
mais le métier de base de cuisinier
reste là quand même et ça nous permet
d'avoir une activité car ce n'est pas la
crise sanitaire qui entamera leur
motivation paul denis voix et son gendre
alexandre mons deux chefs reconnus sur
la place messines se sont associés pour
créer leur propre affaire
poussé par une adrénaline commune les
clients ne manquent déjà un restaurant
l'ambiance d'antan de la clé en discuter
rigoler les retours des clients dit en
direct nous manque mais on se conseille
ce projet d'or alexandre m apporter à
ces plats des saveurs nouvelles et des
notes asiatiques tels que dans ce poulet
taille au piment d'espelette et
gingembre et citron vert mais son
imagination ne s'arrête pas là j'ai
assez de la le tartare de boeuf glace
roquefort pour casser un peu ce plat qui
est traditionnel j'essaie toujours de
trouver le petit truc qu'on connaît pas
trop le combawa l'oeil ou l'audace de la
jeunesse associe à la rigueur de la
tradition les deux hommes ont su allier
des savoir faire complémentaires et
bénéficient aujourd'hui de la fidélité
de leur clientèle de la choucroute
je n'avais pas pensé mais comme vous
nous le suggérer évidemment je ferais
volontiers
et si les commandes sont nombreuses on
est encore bien loin des 70 couverts que
pourrait accueillir la salle on vend nos
plats oui mais quand les gens sont au
restaurant la les ventes additionnelles
c'est à dire qu'on a les apéritifs on a
les vins on a les cafés on a on a quand
même beaucoup plus de chiffres que la
juste en vente à emporter une solution
qu'ils espèrent provisoire et en
attendant le retour des clients et des
coups de feu
les chefs font au mieux pour dresser
leurs plats en barquette en y
additionnant toujours une jolie touche
finale
vous allez voir dans ce reportage
maintenant il n'y a pas d'âge pour la
colocation
nous nous rendons dans les vosges sur la
commune de plainfaing à la rencontre des
premiers pensionnaires de cette maison
pas comme les autres qui accueillent des
personnes âgées à reportage de nos
confrères de viavoice sur place berne à
rentrer chez lui ici dans cette
colocation pour personnes âgées de
plainfaing chacun des huit colocataires
possède sa porte d'entrée privé une
chambre et sa salle de bains personnel
si en venant même un immeuble
par exemple j'ai ramé - canapé bon ça ne
me la télévision le lit mi-septembre
âgées vie a ouvert cet hébergement dans
les vosges une solution alternative à la
maison de retraite classique à son
arrivée et nicole était épuisé et
n'avait plus la force nécessaire pour
s'occuper sereinement de son épouse la
solution pour les retrouver ici c'est
parfait on peut sortir comment veut on
peut aller dehors comme on veut mon mari
continue aller chez le kiné et il faut
par contre ça c'est pas forcément
évident s'adapter à une vie en
collectivité là vous êtes plusieurs je
trouve qu'on est bien fatigué tu ne
pouvais plus la question fait tout pour
moi j'ai l'impression d'être en vacances
[Musique]
une grande pièce à vivre réunit les
colocataires comme une nouvelle famille
et donc sans masquer les auxiliaires de
vie partagent avec eux les tâches de la
vie courante elle le fond de mon coeur
c'est elles ont pris cette habitude la
de gérer une maison de gérer une famille
et on leur laisse cette possibilité de
continuer ça parce que ça risque de leur
enlever sans leur enlève de l'autonomie
puis surtout de l'estimé de soi dans une
atmosphère comme à la maison
six personnes s'occupent de gérer ses
deux co location de 8
une présence rassurante chacun un
bracelet de détresse et les employés
sont logés juste au dessus un modèle de
vie venue de bourgogne franche comté qui
se développe en 2021 60 devrait ouvrir
en france et 300 d'ici quatre ans
nous on s'adresse à des personnes qui
souhaiteraient rompre d'abord incluse
allemands mais aussi des personnes qui
seraient en perte d'autonomie ou des
personnes dépendantes on accueille des
personnes du gir de haut au gir 5
on va recréer leur leur domicile et
essayer de faire en sorte que tout ce
qu'il n'arrivait plus à faire dans leur
domicile il ya des auxiliaires de vie
qu'ils le fassent pour moyennant 1700
euros environ par mois aides déduites un
peu moins que dans un ehpad la crise
sanitaire restreint quant à elle les
visites des familles aux espaces privés
de chaque direction les hôtes france
maintenant où vous allez le voir
les vents forts des derniers jours et
les grandes marées ont causé des dégâts
sur le littoral de toute la région
notamment à ambleteuse dans le pas de
calais symbole de l'érosion la digue est
fragilisée depuis le passage de la
tempête
eleanor en 2017 cette fois c'est un trou
béant qui a été constatée sur le front
de mer comme le montre ce reportage de
caroline fichten nos partenaires de la
chaîne hbo la chaîne de la voix du nord
sur place une nouvelle fois il faut
intervenir en urgence sur la digue
d'ambleteuse
un coup de vent associé à de gros
coefficients de marée il n'en fallait
pas plus pour endommager les ouvrages
comme il ya quatre ans le collectif sos
baie de slack la firme cette digue est
un gruyère c'est tout l'ouvragé qu'il
faut réparer disons depuis la tempête et
rihanna
la situation s'est fortement dégradée et
[Musique]
on peut dire qu'une partie la partie sud
du fond de mer est dans une situation
critique et donc les rustines ne
suffisent plus il va falloir attaquer le
dossier au fond l'ouvragé a été sondé il
existe des fissures des joints traitant
mauvais état la digue d'ambleteuse a
donc besoin d'être rénovés et il faut
s'y atteler urgemment les élus de la
communauté de communes en sont
conscients là il est temps que tout le
monde se mette autour d'une table et que
tout le monde prenne à bras le corps le
dossier érosion et problème on va dire
rencontrées par tous l'élite aura le
littoral on va dire des hauts de france
et puis avancez pas à tourner autour du
pot à chaque fois et dire voilà il ya
sayah sam est donc maintenant il faut
avancer à ambleteuse à marée haute la
dic subi les attaques de la mer le fort
lui non plus n'est pas épargné le
monument historique est à surveiller les
assauts répétés des vagues ne ménage pas
nous partons en corse maintenant pour
rencontrer une jeune collégienne
eva qui a remporté le prix régional
bulle de mémoire
un prix qui propose aux collégiens et
lycéens de réaliser une bande dessinée
autour d'une thématique mémorielle sur
le thème s'engager pour la république
nos confrères de via télé parisé ont
rencontré eva la lauréate
quel titre avez vous donnez à votre
bande dessinée transmettent un passé une
mémoire un engagement c'est l'histoire
d'une grand-mère qui raconte à sa petite
fille pourquoi est-ce qu'elle s'est
engagée
pour la république comment elle transmet
les mémoires justement de nos ancêtres
de ce qui s'est passé pendant la guerre
et en particulier les histoires
d'oradour-sur-glane qui a été très
marquante c'est très important parce que
faut pas oublier en fait ce qui s'est
passé ça peut toujours nous servir en
fait pour ne pas reproduire les erreurs
du passé
avez vous effectué gros cherche
connaissant déjà le village
d'oradour-sur-glane j'ai juste
rechercher plus de détails par rapport à
ce qui s'était passé
les vêtements qu'ils portaient les dates
exactes puis surtout pourquoi les
allemands fait ça en fait
en quoi consiste cette action éducative
ça consiste déjà étudié tout ce qui est
mémoires de guerre et a travaillé sur le
programme d'arts plastiques en même
temps qu'eux
les thèmes de guerre lauréate 2020 du
concours bhl de mémoire à la fois du
prix régional du prix national quand
même donc le pré régionale qui nous a
été délivrée mois de juillet et ensuite
on nous a appelés hla au mois d'octobre
pour nous préciser qu'elle avait aussi
gagné le premier prix national en
candidat libre
le concours bulle de mémoire c'est un
concours qui est organisé par l'office
national des anciens combattants et des
victimes de guerre et y portent sur les
notions de la mémoire d'une part et
également du des conflits du
contemporain donc notamment la seconde
guerre mondiale pour l'établissement si
vous voulez ce type d'activité est
toujours l'occasion de valoriser le
travail des élèves et de faire
travailler les élèves sur des
thématiques aussi importante que la
mémoire que l'histoire en prenant du
plaisir un peu de sport pour finir ce
journal maintenant vous le savez les
compétitions ont lieu à huit clos à
cause de la crise sanitaire mais les
télés locales les retransmettent pour
vous un peu partout dans toutes les
régions
exemple avec ces images de match de hand
ball à cherbourg où la chaîne normande
lcn réalise ses productions depuis ses
studios
tout le programme est à retrouver sur le
site internet de la chaîne normande qui
s'affiche sur cet écran merci à nos
confrères de nous faire profiter de ces
matchs de hand ball voit la fin du grand
jt des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivi sur les chaînes locales et
régionales de la tnt et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition
[Musique]